- [Instructor] Find the
general indefinite integral.
And so we have the integral of two x dx.
Which of the graphs shown below,
which of the graphs below shows
several members of the family?
So if we're talking about,
so if we're taking the
integral of two x dx,
we're talking about the
antiderivative of two x.
And what's that going to be?
Well, it's going to be two x
to the second power.
'Cause this was two x to the first power,
so we increment the exponent to two.
And then we divide by that
newly incremented exponent,
so this is going to be x squared.
And you might have done that
on your own, you said, okay,
I know that the derivative
of x squared is two x,
so the antiderivative
of two x is x squared.
But we aren't quite done yet.
Because remember,
this isn't the only
antiderivative of this.
We could add any constant here.
If we add some constant here
and we take the derivative
of it, we still get two x.
Because the derivative of a
constant with respect to x,
it's not changing with respect to x,
so its derivative is zero.
So the antiderivatives, I
guess you could say here,
take this form,
take the form of x squared plus C.
Now what does that mean visually?
So,
let me draw, I can draw
a neater version of that.
So slightly better.
So if that's my y-axis
and this is my x-axis,
we know what y equals
x squared looks like.
Y equals x squared looks like,
I'll just draw the general shape.
So y equals x squared looks like this.
Now, what happens
if I add a C?
Let's say if I add,
let's say y is equal
to x squared plus two.
And two is a valid C, so we could say,
so let me write this down.
This right over here is
y is equal to x squared.
But remember, and I
guess you could say that,
in this case, our C is zero.
But what if our C was some positive value?
So let's say it is y
is equal to x squared
plus, I don't know, y is
equal to x squared plus five.
Well, then we're going to have
a y-intercept here at five,
so essentially we're just
gonna shift up the graph
by our constant right over
here, which is positive five.
So we shift up by positive five,
and we will get something
that looks like this.
We just shifted it up.
Now, you might be saying, okay,
well, that kind of looks like
this choice right over here.
But this choice also,
also has some choices
that start down here, that
we're adding a constant.
But you remember, this
constant can be any constant.
It could be a negative value.
So in this case, C is five.
In this case, C is zero.
But C could also be negative five.
So C could also be negative five.
So if we wanted to do y is equal
to x squared plus negative five,
which is really x squared minus five,
then the graph would look like this.
It would shift x squared down,
down by five.
So this one is shifted up by five.
This one is shifted down by five.
So you would shift by the constant.
If it's a positive
constant, you're going up.
If it's a negative constant,
you are going down.
So B is definitely
the class of solutions to
this indefinite integral.
You take any, any of the functions
that are represented by these graphs,
you take their derivative,
you're going to get two x.
Or another way to think about it,
the antiderivative of
this or the integral,
the indefinite integral of two x dx
is gonna be x squared plus C,
which would be represented
by things that look like,
so essentially things,
essentially y equals x
squared shifted up or down.
So I could keep drawing
over and over again.